this is I FCT 2006 award for best short
Tommy winter king of K down written and
directed by aaron King touching the
wards and festivals me anything to me no
but yes this is cool now I can have a
title now I can put on my movie I'm an
award-winning filmmaker blah blah so
that's cool festival Sam the more people
see your work the better so that means
something to me if I have to do that to
get the more people to see it then yes
festivals mean something otherwise yeah
I don't make movies thinking I can't
wait to get it into this festival it's
not my angle I don't make movies for
anybody except really myself and maybe
that message will spread to other people
I grew up in Harrisburg Pennsylvania uh
my parents got divorced when I was
little I have two brothers one of them's
a twin so that makes my story a little
different but not really not much it's
just I think the whole point thing is
just cool to know that there's it's like
your best friends always there you have
twice the amount of friends cuz all his
friends who I didn't know thought I was
him so then I did know them I guess that
was different yeah like I said my
story's real similar everyone else's you
know I played sports as a kid I was
pretty good at wrestling but then I
broke my arm my senior year and then I
changed everything I thought I was
destined for scholarship but didn't have
it cuz it broke mar um in wrestling
practice by my assistant coach who never
said sorry just me off and then you know
saying typical stuff their small town so
you drink a lot party loud I guess what
else you really doing small towns except
drink something else good
I I guess when I lived there I I had no
idea what I want to do with myself and
um so I went to Community College little
and all that kind stuff trying to figure
out what I wanted to do I took an acting
class which is kind of fun I used like
the lyrics of a Pogue song to like act
out as a monologue so it was kind of
like poetry monologue thing it wasn't
really now that I understand all i said
it wouldn't have been a good script
there I am
I think I have that's a sweater similar
that but it's orange instead of tan this
is to Aaron call me love Kim with the
heart dotting the I yeah I think that's
first her dad in the bowling alley we
would go to the bowling alley every day
after school and play elevator that
elevator a game and i remember it was
one love an elevator came out i think
cuz i'm saying love in an elevator what
we did finally make out that's it
there's no other girls in your own I'm
never in these kids names what gets me
up in the morning is unfinished business
I feel like I I still feel like the
story that I have to tell isn't told yet
and I'm gonna keep going till I can tell
that story and then i think when i
finish telling that story when I want to
tell a different version of that story
in the different version of that story
and different version of that story so I
think that's what gets me going all the
time and then realizing that where I'm
at is temporary and that only through
hard work and dedication is cheese balls
that sound only through hard work and
percent and constantly working on what
I'm trying to achieve what I be able to
achieve it so I think which is kind of
nicely I gotta say that's why I hang out
in the bathroom just to isolate myself
even more know this why come for
inspiration see zombie survival guide so
I find out all my information right here
Hollywood babble-on good stuff in that
book
essays in philosophy so any time we need
idea we're like on some working on a
book right now as opposed to a movie I
need idea about like where the eats the
individual story how the growth happens
how it occurs sometimes out not really
the zombie survival kit but we'll go
through the philosophy book and now i'm
reading the story I'm philosophy about
our work our country's stronger or
weaker when art exists in the society
that's pretty good was my mom supportive
throwing up growing up it was like it
seemed like it was be whatever you want
to be do this do that but then it turned
into be a doctor be a lawyer be a doctor
be it lawyer but still do whatever you
want I'm gonna support you no matter
what but be a doctor be a lawyer so she
kind of supported it but then she was
like you have to go to college so into
college and then now she's like uh you
should come back you should move back to
Pennsylvania and get a get a real job
what come work for me or what kind of
other job you looking for and do this
and that so I guess he's kind of
supportive but then she's kind of like
aren't you isn't that bug done can't you
move on you know kind of thing I think
she's at that point now but she still
like doesn't say outwardly cuz I don't
ask you for money or anything so
um I guess until I do it she'll be like
do it everyone if I had a son today what
would it be like chill be like go along
whatever kind of thing I'm think you
know whatever man kind of like how I
roll I would like to encourage him to do
whatever he wants still when I wouldn't
say doctor lawyer but i would say please
don't be an actor here's me in junior
high when the the wrestling tournament
twice 87-88 it says this is the second
time I won that tournament this is when
I was a local good wrestling hero so
instead of having to lose weight but I
like doing all that stupid stuff I took
cross Iran I played soccer and then I
took cross-country when I kicked off the
soccer team for not representing what
the school the image the school wants to
represent so they didn't allow me and
Adam to play because we were like punk
rock looking dudes so my friend shade
set gave himself a mohawk and and revolt
then he got benched but then I just ran
cross country in it just you don't have
to lose weight when you run five miles a
day every day you know so it was good
little trick
do I wish I had not come to LA oh no I
don't see where else i could possibly
live other than a la maybe New York City
but I'm too old to live in a shoe box um
yeah no I have no regrets like I totally
would I'm glad I came to LA to be actor
cuz being an actor taught me a lot about
the story of things and what's important
what's not important and how are you
just a piece of the puzzle and how it's
all a giant puzzle so ya know I wouldn't
give that up forty meant absolutely
nothing I feel like when I turned 30 I
had those things will by the time I'm 30
I'm gonna be married family kids all
thats nuts tough famous movie star
movies blau that stuff and then none of
that happened I had to reassess like how
am I better person out of that I'd be
like what what what have I done and how
has that impacted me and I felt like
that did a lot for me at 30 as far as
where I was at in a mental state but
turning 40 on him didn't faze me I
didn't really have anything because
after turning 30 i had such a notion
preconceived notion that it just drove
me crazy now turning for you then I
didn't have any eyes just like well I'm
turning 40 doesn't mean anything except
the need to get rolling can't stop
moving it's usually where i get my TV
time in well on air says black but I
feel as the movie maker you shouldn't
ain't you you shouldn't taint your
creative vision with commercials
consumerism and all that crap they want
you to believe and watch and listen to
dude I want to quit yes I'm always
working on something like if I'm not
writing that i'm working on pop art and
that's kind of stupid cuz it's pop art
but whatever what's pop art really it's
create being creative should I quit that
and then I got back on writing writing a
book this time though not a movie and
then i'll probably quit that hopefully
by Christmas but that'll be done and
then I'll go and then I'll start working
on a movie or a web series
Hannah and I probably won't quit that
for a while and then when I quit that
i'll go into anything I don't know so I
guess I want to quit but I'll never quit
because I feel like you know everyone's
drew every every life's about the
journey and like the the path I guess
they say it's about the journey I say
it's about the path and like you have to
continue to stay on this path or else
you're going to be miserable and that's
what I think so based on that thinking I
can't ever stop I could switch what I'm
being creative about but I can never
stop so if I would quit one aspect I
just go to the other or the next to the
next but I'll never quit never stop this
makes it hard cuz you know then I can't
really leave LA cuz we're also gonna go
never stop fighting to the fight is done
this is the fight you gotta keep the
body good get the mind good so you can
get creative this is where all the ideas
happen it's not on the bike or in the
bathroom it's in front of computer
what do I think about asking celebrities
for a job I say try it cuz I think it's
a good idea but well anything amount out
of it I doubt it uh I'd like I said I
asked Robert Rodriguez for a job that
didn't work I think I talked to UM
Stephen Baldwin and Tucson for a job and
on whatever movie is working on he said
no or he said just keep acting man um
yeah you know but you know maybe you got
lucky towards shot you know it's like
you don't know unless you try right the
best movie line ever uh chief trying to
pick the or I mean uh Jack Nicholson
trying to pick the washing machine up or
whatever and one flew over the cuckoo's
nest at least I tried goddammit let me
start drying my part it's give me
goosebumps so yeah you know you gotta
try but I don't know if anything would
work out of it or not what brought me to
LA partly the weather because Arizona
sucks you know pennsylvania weather
sucks it raining all the time Arizona
didn't rain up here it hardly ever rains
but that's all right it's not supposed
to and to be in the movie business I
guess would be one of the big things cuz
I felt like on this this journey like I
couldn't it couldn't stop in Tucson it
had to like go further I had to keep
going and going so I came here to you
know the fight final fight I guess I
should probably 24 cuz I came here for
pilot season in a Volkswagen bug with
three other people from Tucson we came
in February and then we audited some
acting class and stuff like that and
then
I didn't have any money but I wasn't
gonna let that stop me and all these
people were going so my my house was my
Volkswagen bug it was kind of rough for
all you young filmmakers if you ever
gonna come to LA and be homeless get a
big car that's some smart advice right
there asleep in the bug sucks my knees
hurt every day is loud it's cold so I
came here during that time from februari
through februari march april may june i
think i stay for five months then then I
came back again a year later to stay
first night I got here I don't remember
what day of the week it was but we all
want to eat at the Spaghetti Factory and
I remember I got all this leftover food
and it's just like wow that's a lot of
food and I don't i think i paid for the
food which would be weird because i
didn't have any money but i probably
paid for the food because i didn't want
the people i was with to know that i
didn't have any money that i was gonna
be sleeping in my car and basically be
homeless all down here so we did that
and then it was around ten o'clock and
everyone's like but I'm tired we're
gonna go to sleep I was a guy while I'll
see you later I'm gonna go find a hotel
somewhere and the dude was like we
should this was West would do so you
should I go east you know towards
hollywood find something cheaper so I
was alright and I have no idea where I'm
at I remember driving down Santa Monica
Boulevard and see in the Beverly Hills
sign
and then I went to this starbucks cuz i
got familiarity starbucks and you know
we're sleeping in your car you don't
really want to you know sleep you're
like stay up as long as possible so i go
to starbucks drinking coffee till they
close and then then I just drive around
forever forever forever forever I'm like
well where we gonna sleep I don't
know and I'm getting really tired even
though I just drank two large coffees
getting tired probably from overload and
driving eight and a half hours uh so
then I'm like well I'll just go into
Beverly Hills and sleeved you know I
mean like spare the hills it's gotta be
like the safest place on earth right so
I go in I parked on some random street
in Beverly Hills and I'm like now you
know that's cool hanging out I wake up
to do do do do well and uh it's a
girl car flashlight shining girl car I
don't know what to expect I get out of
the car you didn't say please get out of
the car so it's not a cop it's not a
robber cuz about a Robert Rob of guy to
Volkswagen doesn't make sense so I wrote
on the window and it's freezing cold out
cuz it's februari like what you can't
sleep in your car this Beverly Hills
like what you can't sleep your card it's
been feels you know where you're at I
said yeah I'm in Beverly Hills you can't
sleep in your car just screaming all
time that's alright i do you got go i
think but i got nowhere else to go man
it's my first night here I don't know
where else to go and uh and he's a get
you get over reals that's like man I
don't know where else to go go in alley
the parking alley just get off the
street so they let me park in the alley
so slept for like another hour and a
half and then it conveniently enough is
trash day and they pick up the trash of
like 630 in the morning there I'd I wake
up to boom boom boom dropping the giant
trash cans down and I'm like I kind of
panicked cuz i'm waking up a holy
what but again and i just typed a
leather
went to Venice Beach I got harassed by
homeless people ask me for cigarettes
and now I just SAT there and listened to
some church message at the beach and I
remember I was like uh god I'll come the
church if you bring the Sun out cuz I
was freezing it's freezing cold i was
only person on the beach the Sun came
out God answered my prayers sun came out
good for him go God that I made a deal
with him that I have to go back to
church have venice beach every weekend I
don't know if I did that i've been
criticized i think by not following her
by like people that have followed that
followed the herd their whole life and
maybe they amounted that what they
needed to melt to in their head and then
I guess look any black won't you know
watch you just get a job and do this you
know it'll be easier maybe maybe not
though maybe it won't be easier just not
too long ago I was a full-time and I
hated it I mean it was fine but you know
I found myself angry often and I think I
was angry because I was neglecting my
path and and that's what caused the
anger and I think I think it's possible
perhaps to follow your path while
working and I think the best scenario is
working on your path as your work
so for me I guess yes it's better to not
have the security and be able to do what
i want as opposed to following the mold
the cookie cutter mold the trade-off of
the less secure is worth it for me with
nothing to lose means you have
everything to gain so I kind of like
that mentality freedom's just another
word for nothing left to lose yes Kris
Kristofferson yes makes me wonder really
in hindsight if I was stressed out
because I told myself to be stressed out
kind of thing like I made it happen like
if you thought I thought it so much in
my head that I was gonna be stressed out
that it happened um or I was just as
stressed out I don't really know power
of the thinking though right you can do
anything they wanted me to work on
Christmas Eve and I was like and
Christmas Day because there's some
stupid inventory and I was like knocking
I'm going out of town but then i went
there i went into work anyway well then
my boss called me and left a message on
my phone he said so i came into work
today and you weren't there which is a
bowl a flat-out lie and for some reason
I was so stressed out at the time that
it called me it caused me to have a
panic attack / heart attack kind of
thing I don't really know what it was
but either way chest our certain body
goes kind of numbed start sweating
everything's just like scariest
because i have no idea it's never
happened before that go the hospital
they gave me pills and then then i went
back into work after that christmas
was over they gave me more stress leave
which i kept getting over and over again
because i was stressed out my brain I
couldn't sleep which was probably one of
the best things that ever happened me be
quite Amish because it gave me time to
uh for one I realized I didn't want to
do any of that stuff and if I was going
to play this game of trying to fit into
the mold I had
find another way and it couldn't be
through full time where it takes up all
my time it's the one thing I learned
from all the studying of the human
condition and the patterns and meeting
the people in LA and all this and that
is that you just got to keep doing what
you're doing like you got to have this
pat like we all have this path right and
we just got to keep doing it I think
that's like the big thing I learned from
me from all this studying that the only
way to be happy yeah you work jobs and
all it's not stuff but the only way to
be happy is to do what is that you do
whatever that is you just have to keep
doing and I think I think that was a big
thing I learned from all that it's good
good advice I think this chair gets
uncomfortable I'm a bartender so I get
interaction to people that way but if I
wasn't then i would think I'd freak out
like I would be I would have social
phobia because it would be I would go
out so seldom that it would be very
weird
yes it's isolating but it's worth it
you're just going to make a little tiny
movie with nobody no names in it and of
course people were gonna flock to a
movie with names in it because that's
what they need to see oh oh it's
familiar oh I like it oh wow even though
it's not an end up not an independent
movie it's not even a film festival
movie it's like a big budget movie that
didn't have any money for advertising so
they're gonna put it in the film
festival circuit that's what you're
going up against I feel like all work
and no play makes Jack a dull boy like
sometimes I sit in that isolated room of
mine in front of the computer far too
much like I should be out doing way more
stuff so I think it has cost me that
somewhat as far as relationships i don't
mean I don't have a girlfriend now but I
guess it could be getting in a way that
maybe I don't know but I don't think it
ever cost me relationship no but
definitely could be going out more
what's gonna be different about the year
to come well if I'm homeless i will have
somewhere to sleep so that's good hmm i
think the other thing that's different
is uh will be different is acting on
every impulse like not being like aw
that was stupid you know like none of
that stuff like that's dumb I'm not
gonna do that I think I think I need to
do that more often all the time that's
why I made the pop art because I just
thought it was funny and it was an
impulse so I did it think I look at
people and think like could you be my
mentor
mm-hmm I train is my mentor
that makes any sense keep going up that
hill
you get there what do I admire about my
mom work ethic she was just to always
keep going always keep going i always
keep going gotta work gotta work that'll
work see a single single parent raising
three kids you know that's tough three
boys at that so you know stay calm and
carry on it's like that coffee mug says
just keep going keep going keep going
keep going keep going so I got for my
mom keep going and go I grew up
religious right so I I think that's also
the balls you in kind of with guilt and
negative group to me religions it's not
supposed to be negative and it just
through fear and everything gets you to
conform to its ways it's like and you
know so I think all that was so growing
up with that I can't say that I felt
oppressed growing up but I think as I
always knew that there was more kind of
thing so I went with them so I started
studying philosophy and stuff like that
what this is what I'm supposed to do i'm
supposed to go to college i'm supposed
to work i'm supposed to have 2.5 kids I
supposed to be married by the time on 20
I guess it depends with family living
right some towns is 22 other towns it's
30 whatever yeah so basically yeah so
you don't have to do other stuff that
every all these preconceived notions
that you had growing up you can just
throw those away the name of my book is
how I learned to like yellow mustard
these are my adventures for the most
part but they're uh but some of the
details are changed just one guys
adventures I just kind of want to see it
in a book format double-sided pages I'm
kind of cooled be like look there it is
maybe it's just a bucket list thing but
I try to all right I don't try cuz i
actually do i make it a part of my
everyday that i have to do this stuff
and it brings me get your creative
juices flowing you know so it's kind of
fun you know it's like ah yeah that's
what I'm told to be doing right yeah
someone gave me this book when I was 15
I think I think i mighta came to terms
with fear faster it would help me to be
like ah that's nothing we're at the time
you think it's everything but it's not
right that's just fear yeah I think all
the same stuff you fear as a kid you
fear as an adult unless you can read
this book and get over it man same ones
kids face I think everyone you know
whatever the future what the future
holds maybe I don't know maybe people
fear dying I don't really feel you're
dying but
what I got from the book would be a
reminder of hope and that uh never
stopped fighting to the fight is done
why do I think most people give up
because they're lazy or they want that
into it anyway I would think more so
they weren't that into it anyway kind of
like well kinda like that program thing
if I have to go to college after this
after that oh so I'm expected to do this
like when you come to LA you have to
have a screenplay right everybody has to
have a screenplay that's just the thing
so I think people write a screenplay
whatever just so they have it but yet
they're not really into it they're just
doing it because they think it's a
requirement so I think those are the
people that give up cuz they're not that
into it I think you can only make art
for yourself you know so maybe it is for
me but not really yeah I wrote it for me
the first time now it's not for me now
it's for other people I guess or maybe
people that might know me or think they
know me then I can read it then they
might know me better I guess you know
sometimes what it does do is it say say
I'm in a slump of some sort you know
wake up on the wrong side of the bed or
whatever then I Creed the book and then
I'm like ah alright I can do this right
sometimes I read that reader for
inspiration that seems to work
everything you were programmed as a
child you can get over and in at what
level that can you free yourself from
all these things and then you know
really be yourself until you get out of
that until you can get out of that jail
then you can't really be yourself so
that's kind of freedom from taught
oppression free yourself from programs
programming then you can be yourself the
way to develop self-confidence is to do
the thing you fear and get a record of
successful experiences behind you
destiny is not a matter of chance it's a
matter of choice is not a thing could be
waited for it is the thing to be
achieved
william jennings bryan said that
you